Musique lente dramatique
...
-C'est trop beau, hein.
T'as vu les nuages, là,
qui sont vraiment rouges
super puissants ?
...
Je me demande si on va revoir
le soleil aujourd'hui.
Peut-être qu'il est déjà trop bas,
sous l'horizon.
...
On va voir.
On va guetter.
S'il sort, il va sortir juste là.
...
D'ici quelques jours,
c'est le début
de la nuit polaire.
Là, on est vraiment
à la frontière jour/nuit.
...
Tu comprends ce que je te dis
avec cette lumière,
ces fameuses lumières
du mois d'octobre.
Tu vois, ça, si je le vois pas
dans l'année,
j'ai un besoin physique
de voir ça.
Y a rien de plus beau.
Là, t'arrives à voir,
qui se dessine
tout au fond du fjord,
ce que je préfère.
Ca, c'est un des plus gros glaciers
de la région.
On devrait s'en rapprocher
dans les prochaines heures.
...
Là, on est en train de se rapprocher
de ce glacier de fou,
qui s'appelle
Nordenskioldbreen.
C'est un de mes glaciers
préférés au Svalbard.
J'en reviens pas
à quel point on s'approche.
Regarde toutes ces crevasses.
C'est un des glaciers
qui sont
les plus crevassés par ici.
T'as l'impression de voir
les entrailles du glacier.
...
Ce qui est fou,
c'est que le glacier change
ultra rapidement ici,
comme tu le sais.
Chaque année, en fait,
il est différent.
Là, cette grotte de glace,
il n'y était pas,
il y a quelques mois.
Ah là là, c'est trop beau.
Tu vois, tous ces glaciers
qui se rapprochent de l'océan,
ce sont les glaciers
qui se retirent aussi
le plus rapidement au Svalbard.
L'océan se réchauffe vachement,
aussi, bien sûr,
les températures de l'air.
Toute cette glace qui est
en contact avec l'eau,
c'est la glace qui fond
le plus rapidement
et qui se retire,
qui remonte sur terre.
C'est un mécanisme de protection
du glacier, qui recule, recule.
Une fois qu'il est sur terre,
il fond un peu moins rapidement.
Oh là là, c'est tellement beau.
D'avoir cette petite...
couche de neige qui met
les reliefs en valeur,
c'est somptueux.
Près de ces grottes,
il y a plein d'oiseaux.
On les voit,
ils sont tout petits et lointains.
Au front du glacier,
t'as un contraste
entre l'eau douce du glacier
et l'eau salée de l'océan.
Toutes les petites crevettes
et les organismes
qui aiment l'eau salée
se retrouvent tout à coup
baignés dans l'eau douce,
sont perdus,
remontent à la surface,
et les oiseaux
vont les becqueter.
On dirait du marbre, presque.
C'est fou.
Je crois que le bleu de la glace,
ça nous hypnotise tous.
C'est en grande partie la raison
pour laquelle je suis glaciologue :
voir des trucs comme ça.
C'est vraiment rare de pouvoir voir
la toute base du glacier.
La raison pour laquelle
la glace est bleue,
c'est parce que la glace
qui est à la base,
elle est tellement écrasée
sous le poids
de la glace au-dessus
que toutes les bulles d'air
prises au piège dans la glace
se sont échappées
sous la pression.
Plus il y a de bulles d'air,
plus la glace est blanche.
Moins il y en a,
plus elle est bleue.
Le bleu est la seule couleur
qui ne passe pas
au travers de la glace,
qui rebondit en quelque sorte,
et c'est pour ça qu'on voit
par nos yeux que la glace est bleue.
C'est fou, quoi.
Là, c'est sûrement un endroit
qui est très actif,
où on a ce qu'on appelle
ces fameux vêlages d'icebergs,
là où la glace se casse,
tombe dans l'océan,
et forme ces icebergs
qui contribuent
à l'augmentation
du niveau des océans.
Musique lente dramatique
...
Oh, il est magnifique.
Je vois plein de signes de la fonte
qui a eu lieu cet été.
Ca a été un été juste désastreux
ici pour les glaciers au Svalbard.
En fait, chaque été est pire
que l'été précédant.
...
Et là, les glaciers
ont perdu vraiment
un énorme volume de glace
ces derniers mois.
Même si c'est très beau,
je ne peux pas m'empêcher
de remarquer tous ces petits signes
qui nous montrent
que le glacier
s'est vraiment aminci,
il a perdu
beaucoup d'épaisseur.
On voyait pas du tout
autant de roche, l'année dernière.
Et le problème, c'est que...
C'est un vrai cercle vicieux
qui se met en place ici.
Tu vois, le glacier est
en contact avec l'océan
et l'océan se réchauffe de façon
catastrophique dans l'Arctique.
Mais aussi toutes ces roches...
Plus il y a de roches exposées
autour du glacier,
plus elles emmagasinent
la chaleur du soleil
et plus le glacier se retire.
Et là, tu vois, en fait,
c'est des lambeaux,
ce qu'il reste ici.
...
Tu vois, même si ça reste
un monstre de glace,
tu te rends compte
qu'ils sont hyper fragiles
et sensibles à ce qu'il se passe.
Ah, petit oiseau...
Evidemment, ces glaciers contribuent
à tout un écosystème ici aussi.
C'est pas important
que pour la glace, c'est sûr.
Mais c'est magique.
Tu vois qu'il a quand même
encore de l'énergie, ce glacier.
Franchement, il se bat.
Le fait qu'il soit très crevassé,
ça montre qu'il y a énormément
de glace qui pousse,
qui essaye de bouger toute
cette masse en direction de l'océan.
Il en a encore sous le pied,
Nordenskioldbreen.
Il est connecté
à une énorme calotte,
juste derrière les montagnes.
Donc, il a de la chance,
il a encore pas mal
de décennies devant lui, mais...
Mais là, en partie basse,
tout montre
que le glacier est
en train de subir
un changement
climatique catastrophique.
...
Et je sais pas
si t'arrives à voir,
mais on voit ces veines,
ces lignes dans la glace.
En fait, chaque ligne,
c'est une année d'accumulation
de neige sur le glacier.
C'est un peu
comme les cernes d'un arbre.
En fait, si on le faisait
comme il faut, tu peux compter
le nombre de ces lignes
pour reconstruire
l'âge du glacier.
Donc, là, on est en face
d'un sacré vieillard, quand même.
Cette glace a facilement
plusieurs centaines d'années.
Tout ça, toute cette mémoire,
on est en train de la voir
disparaître sous nos yeux.
Mais il y a toujours un aspect fou,
quand tu regardes ces glaciers,
c'est que pour moi,
c'est la pureté absolue.
Il n'y a pas plus beau,
je trouve, sur Terre,
du moins dans l'Arctique,
que des glaciers pareils.
Mais tu sais que s'il y a un morceau
de glace qui se décroche,
franchement, on est tellement
proches, qu'on est morts.
Donc, il y a toujours ce contraste
où tu te dis "c'est super beau",
et en même temps,
tu sais que c'est "deadly".
Ils sont toujours
plus forts que toi.
Musique lente dramatique
Si tout le monde pouvait voir ça
sur Terre... T'imagines ?
...
Je pense que si les gens avaient
l'occasion de voir ça,
de sentir l'air
qui vient des glaciers...
T'as vraiment l'impression
de sentir le pouls du glacier.
...je suis sûre
qu'on s'intéresserait beaucoup plus
à ce qui se passe ici
et, déjà, qu'on comprendrait
leur force.
Quand tu vois ça...
Et ça, c'est un glacier
parmi des centaines
de milliers d'autres.
Quand tu vois ça,
tu comprends la force du truc.
C'est ça
que j'essaye de partager,
de montrer à quel point
c'est beau...
C'est magnifique,
ces monstres de glace.
...et à quel point,
malgré leur beauté,
malgré le fait qu'ils soient
gigantesques, c'est ultra fragile.
Il y a besoin de peu de choses
pour que toute cette glace parte.
Et tout ça, ça contribue
à l'élévation
du niveau des océans.
En plein été, tu imagines
des températures assez hautes,
énormément d'eau
qui ruisselle du glacier,
et sans arrêt...
Heïdi imite des chutes dans l'eau.
Sans arrêt, t'as des vêlages,
des morceaux de glace
qui se décrochent
du front du glacier.
T'as l'impression d'être
dans un terrain miné,
que c'est la guerre,
tellement le glacier est actif,
tellement il est vivant
et tellement il fond vite.
...
Et maintenant que l'hiver arrive,
tout se calme un peu.
...
Mais tu vois,
toutes ces petites îles,
toutes les roches qu'on a
juste à côté de nous,
ça, il y a quelques années,
c'était sous la glace.
C'était complètement
sous la glace.
Musique émouvante
...
Même le trou, là-haut,
ça n'y était pas
il y a quelques mois.
Là, tu vois, le glacier est en train
de se faire attaquer de partout.
Ce qui me touche, c'est que ça fait
longtemps que je connais ce glacier.
C'était en 2008, je crois,
la première fois
où je suis allée sur le glacier,
le premier que j'ai étudié
au Svalbard...
A l'époque,
j'étais étudiante en licence.
Je commençais mes études
en glaciologie.
On nous avait fait camper juste là,
sur la gauche, pendant 15 jours.
Je me souviens,
avec mes profs,
avoir marché
au milieu des crevasses.
Pas de cordes, je me souviens plus
si on avait des crampons.
Les profs nous disaient juste :
"Evitez de tomber
dans les crevasses."
A l'époque,
on se rendait pas du tout compte
à quel point
le glacier est dangereux.
Maintenant, ce n'est plus autorisé.
Ils ne font plus comme ça
à l'université.
Mais ouais, ça fait longtemps
que je le croise, ce glacier.
Ca me désole de voir l'état
dans lequel il est aujourd'hui.
...
T'as l'impression d'avoir
des écailles de dragon
qui caressent les rochers.
...
Je suis tellement contente
qu'on voie ces couleurs.
...
Musique contemplative
Musique douce
...
Mon glacier,
voilà ce que tu es devenu.
Des éclats de glace partout,
que tu laisses
dans l'océan glacial Arctique.
...
Regarde-moi ça.
Eparpillés à droite à gauche,
pris au piège dans la banquise.
...
Le reste de ton corps.
Ces icebergs ne sont
plus du tout connectés à toi.
...
Dès que l'été sera venu,
ils vont fondre,
attaqués par le soleil,
par les températures.
...
D'ici quelques mois,
il n'y aura plus rien
à cet endroit.
...
Tout cet univers blanc,
gigantesque...
...
...se fait attaquer
de toutes parts, aujourd'hui.
Pourtant, ça fait longtemps
que t'es là,
si longtemps,
que tu façonnes ce paysage,
que tu amènes ton eau
dans l'océan Arctique,
cette eau si riche qui fertilise
les fjords et l'océan tout autour.
...
Musique contemplative
C'est fou de se sentir
comme à la maison
dans un endroit pareil...
...
...alors que tout est froid,
tout est blanc.
Tout est glacé.
...
Mais entourée par tes icebergs,
c'est là que je me sens bien.
...
Musique douce
Il y a quelque chose
de magique, ici...
...
...quelque chose d'indescriptible.
C'est jamais pareil.
Il y a toujours quelque chose
qui s'y passe,
que ce soit le vent qui caresse
ces dunes de neige...
...
...ces icebergs qui se décrochent
pour être pris au piège
dans leur banquise...
...
Les sons, le manque d'odeurs...
...le froid qui nous paralyse
mais qui, aussi,
nous remet bien
les idées en place.
...
C'est vraiment un des environnements
les plus puissants,
un des environnements
les plus mortels aussi.
...
Je me demande si tu te rends compte
que chaque iceberg
qui se décroche de toi
a des conséquences partout ailleurs
sur terre.
...
Chaque graine,
chaque bloc de glace que tu perds...
...affecte des milliers,
voire des millions de personnes,
bien au-delà de l'Arctique.
...
Est-ce que tu sais aussi
que ton eau,
elle permet à des millions,
voire des milliards de personnes,
de boire,
d'avoir de l'agriculture,
de produire de l'électricité ?
...
Alors aujourd'hui,
pour te remercier...
...on est carrément
en train de te faire disparaître.
...
Je crois qu'on n'a vraiment
rien compris.
...
Pourtant, on a tellement
besoin de toi...
...
...de ton eau,
de tes couleurs, de ta glace.
...
Si tu pouvais parler,
je me demande ce que tu nous dirais.
Je me demande si tu nous demanderais
de nous battre pour toi,
ou juste d'accepter les choses
telles qu'elles sont.
...
Je me demande si tu souffres,
si tu ressens ce qui se passe.
...
Alors qu'aujourd'hui, regarde-toi.
Tes entrailles
complètement explosées,
tes crevasses qui te traversent...
...
J'ai bien conscience que...
Quand je te regarde aujourd'hui,
je sais que plus jamais
je te verrai aussi gros,
aussi beau,
aussi majestueux,
qu'année après année,
tu ne fais que reculer,
tu ne fais que partir.
...
C'est vraiment une mort
à petit feu.
C'est une agonie qui continue
et qui n'en finit pas.
...
Pour moi, c'est impossible
d'imaginer ces paysages sans toi,
sans toi qui les couronnes,
sans toi qui les domines.
...
Je te vois vraiment
comme un sage, comme un ancêtre...
...
...comme celui qui a
toujours été là.
...
Quoi qu'il arrive,
moi, je te regarde.
...
J'aimerais que tu tiennes.
Et hop, sur la plage !
Elle rit.
Sur la plage d'Adventfjorden,
qui est le fjord qui est
directement connecté
à la capitale du Svalbard,
Longyearbyen.
Là, on est début mai.
Comme vous pouvez le voir,
y a pas du tout, du tout de banquise
dans le fjord.
Ce fjord, en fait, est connecté
à un fjord encore plus grand
qui est juste ici, sur la droite
qui s'appelle Isfjorden.
Cette année, ça a été
super compliqué pour la banquise.
En fait, ça fait des mois, ici,
que les scientifiques
de l'université prévoient
que ça va être
presque un point de non-retour
pour les fjords ici, au Svalbard.
Dès le mois de novembre,
ils nous annonçaient
que la température de l'eau
était beaucoup trop chaude.
Je suis sûre que si je mets
les doigts dedans,
ça va pas être à 20 degrés.
Ouais, elle est
quand même bien fraîche.
Mais ce qui se passe,
c'est que ces fjords reçoivent
de l'eau qui vient du Gulf Stream.
Cette eau, malheureusement,
est de plus en plus chaude.
On a de l'eau qui est beaucoup
trop chaude, ici, au Svalbard,
dans ce fjord-là en particulier,
pour que la banquise se forme.
C'est fou de voir que tout est lié,
que la perte de cette banquise
au nord,
eh ben elle impacte directement
notre population,
nos écosystèmes, notre économie,
beaucoup plus au sud,
en Europe et en France.
Ca dépend vraiment que de nous,
ce qu'on veut faire
de cette banquise.
Chaque tonne d'énergie fossile
que l'on brûle,
que ce soit du gaz naturel,
du pétrole ou du charbon,
tout ça, ça participe activement
à la disparition de la banquise.
Donc très clairement,
l'avenir de la banquise,
il est entre nos mains,
et notre avenir est directement lié
à celui de la banquise.
Donc, son avenir et notre avenir
ne tiennent plus qu'à nous,
aujourd'hui.
Musique contemplative
...
Ce qu'on est en train de voir, là,
c'est un énorme méandre
qui a été créé par l'eau
au contact de la glace
et on a du mal à imaginer
à quel point cette glace,
elle peut complètement changer
le comportement du glacier.
D'avoir
de l'eau liquide ici,
déjà, ça réchauffe
le glacier de l'intérieur
et cette eau,
au bout d'un moment,
elle arrive toujours
à trouver le moyen
d'aller
à la base du glacier
et lorsqu'elle arrive
à la base du glacier,
elle peut lubrifier
le mouvement du glacier
sur un socle rocheux
et en accélérer le mouvement,
donc d'étudier ces cavernes
de glace, ces cathédrales de glace,
c'est ultra important
pour comprendre l'interaction
entre l'eau et la glace
et la dynamique du glacier.
Musique douce
...
Ici, on voit un truc
qui est assez rare, en fait,
dans ce genre de glacier,
qui a l'air statique,
qui ne bouge plus du tout
aujourd'hui,
ce qu'on voit,
c'est l'indication que,
il y a un sacré
petit bout de temps,
probablement il y a 100-150 ans,
le glacier était au contraire
ultra actif,
ultra dynamique,
et là, on voit bien la différence
dans la couleur de la glace.
De part et d'autre
de cet endroit très sombre,
on a de la glace de glacier normale.
C'est quoi, de la glace normale ?
En fait, c'est tout simplement
de la glace
qui est remplie
de petites bulles d'air
qui s'est créée
par l'accumulation de neige
sur des dizaines,
voire des centaines d'années
et ça, on s'attend à voir ça
dans tous les glaciers,
c'est normal,
et tout d'un coup... Prr !
On a cette veine ici où on a,
certes, de la glace,
mais on voit qu'elle est
complètement transparente
et qu'il n'y a plus une seule
bulle d'air à l'intérieur,
ce qui est assez fou,
et de part et d'autre
de cette zone toute noire,
on a des sédiments
et en fait,
ce qu'on est en train
de regarder ici,
c'est une ancienne crevasse,
une ancienne fracture
qui s'est formée à un moment
où le glacier était hyper actif
dans le sens où le glacier
bougeait très vite à l'époque,
le glacier s'étirait
dans tous les sens,
ça formait ces fameux "cracs",
ces fameuses fractures
et ce qu'on voit aussi,
c'est cette zone sans bulles d'air
qui est faite de glace, mais pas
de glace de glacier, cette fois-ci,
c'est tout simplement de l'eau
qui a dû remplir ce crac
à la fin de la période
de dynamique de la glace
et ce qui est génial,
c'est que cette énorme fracture,
on la retrouve
tout du long,
donc on voit que la fracture
continue vraiment
de part et d'autre ici du tunnel
et elle continue...
Si on n'avait pas ça,
on aurait du mal
à reconstruire
l'histoire du glacier,
donc ça nous permet
de comprendre que, finalement,
les glaciers peuvent changer
très vite de comportement.
Musique douce
...
Si on était venus ici
il y a un an,
le sol de la grotte de glace,
il serait juste ici.
Ce qu'on a ici,
c'est l'ancien sol
sur lequel les gens marchaient
au printemps de l'année dernière.
Ce qui s'est passé,
c'est que l'eau de fonte,
elle creuse ces galeries
qui sont monumentales,
ces canyons, en fait,
dans le glacier,
et l'eau
est vraiment capable
de couper dans la glace
comme dans du beurre.
C'est vraiment
ultra puissant.
On se retrouve
avec des canyons gigantesques
comme celui qu'on a
au-dessus de notre tête.
Là, maintenant,
on doit avoir
20 ou 30 mètres de glace
et ce qui se passe,
c'est que ce canyon,
le glacier, en fait,
il faut comprendre qu'il essaye
toujours de le refermer,
donc pendant l'hiver,
lorsqu'il n'y a plus du tout d'eau
qui va continuer à creuser,
lorsqu'il n'y a plus rien
qui maintient
ces canyons ouverts,
la glace, naturellement,
de glacier
va essayer de boucher
tous ces trous.
La glace, elle a l'air dure
comme ça,
mais elle est quand même
un peu visqueuse
et ainsi,
on trouve ces canyons qui,
petit à petit,
vont se refermer.
Elle tape sur la glace.
Sons graves
Le son devient
de plus en plus aigu.
"Symphonie pour un glacier".
Elle rit.
Musique douce haletante
...
Ce glacier, c'est...
de loin un des glaciers
que je connais le plus sur terre.
J'y ai passé des jours,
des semaines, des mois
à mesurer sa taille, à mesurer
à quelle vitesse ce glacier
réagit
au dérèglement climatique
et en revenant ici aujourd'hui,
je remarque déjà,
rien qu'en regardant le front
du glacier, là où on est,
à quel point il a reculé
ces dernières années.
C'est un glacier qui s'est
complètement métamorphosé
en réagissant
au dérèglement climatique.
Il faut dire qu'ici, au Svalbard,
on est à l'endroit sur terre
qui se réchauffe
le plus vite aujourd'hui.
On mesure que le Svalbard
se réchauffe six à sept fois
plus vite que le reste
de la planète.
Cri d'oiseau
Je pense que le petit oiseau
qui est dans la falaise
est d'accord avec moi.
Les changements qu'on observe ici
sont juste hallucinants.
Ce glacier-là,
c'est ce qu'on appelle
"un petit glacier",
il fait 400 km de long,
mais c'est un glacier
parmi les 200 000 glaciers
dans le monde
et on sait qu'aujourd'hui,
tous ces glaciers
réagissent
au dérèglement climatique
et une des conséquences
de leur perte de glace,
de leur perte de volume,
c'est notamment
l'élévation
du niveau des océans.
Même si t'as un glacier ici,
au Svalbard,
qui perd de la glace,
cette glace,
elle va faire augmenter le niveau
des océans partout sur terre
et on sait que tous les océans
sont connectés,
donc que l'on habite
dans les Philippines,
que l'on habite à Miami
ou que l'on habite au Havre,
eh ben, on remarque
déjà aujourd'hui
que le niveau des océans augmente
et que cette augmentation,
c'est ça qui est vraiment terrible,
s'accélère.
Aujourd'hui, on est
en train de suivre
le pire scénario possible
au niveau du dérèglement climatique
et toute cette glace, on sait
que si elle fondait aujourd'hui,
elle pourrait augmenter
le niveau des océans de 65 mètres
et sur terre, juste entre 0
et 10 mètres d'altitude,
il y a 700 millions de personnes
et vraiment, ces espaces littoraux,
c'est des espaces économiques
qui sont extrêmement riches,
c'est là où il y a
le plus de croissance
et où il y a le plus de croissance
au niveau des populations
et on sait que ces populations,
elles commencent déjà à se déplacer,
mais il y aura des déplacements
de plus en plus importants
qui vont toucher
non pas que ces populations-là,
mais tous les autres territoires
sur terre
et il faudra bien
que ces populations-là
et ces activités économiques
se déplacent
et donc, que l'on habite
au Svalbard ou pas,
on va tous être touchés
par la fonte de ces glaciers
et par l'augmentation
du niveau des océans.
Musique douce
...
Je travaille pour AMAP,
l'Arctic Monitoring
and Assessment Programme,
qui est un des groupes
du Conseil de l'Arctique,
et on a un rôle clé
dans la transmission
des connaissances
scientifiques.
On est l'intermédiaire
entre les scientifiques,
le monde académique
et les gouvernements.
C'est les gouvernements
qui nous approchent
avec une liste de questions
et c'est à nous
d'organiser le travail scientifique
pour pouvoir y répondre,
donc nous, on leur produit
des connaissances,
mais aussi, ce qui est important,
des recommandations.
Une fois qu'on partage cette science
avec les gouvernements,
nous, ce qu'on souhaite voir,
et ce que le reste de la planète
souhaite voir aussi,
ce sont des réactions, des décisions
prises le plus rapidement possible
et on voit qu'il y a certains sujets
où les gouvernements
réagissent très vite,
notamment, au niveau de l'Arctique,
tout ce qui touche la santé,
tout ce qui touche
la dégradation des écosystèmes.
Les pays sont en train de réagir
et de mettre en place
vraiment des solutions
très concrètes
pour leurs populations qui habitent
au nord du cercle polaire.
Il y a d'autres sujets
qui sont super "touchy",
où là, ça avance
beaucoup moins vite,
c'est tout ce qui touche
aux énergies fossiles
parce que, pour l'instant,
c'est clair que l'Arctique
est une des dernières régions
où il y a encore énormément
d'énergies fossiles,
que ce soit du charbon,
au Svalbard,
il y a du charbon de partout,
du gaz et du pétrole,
il y a beaucoup de terres rares,
de minerais rares au niveau
du Groenland, notamment,
et là, on se rend compte que,
malheureusement,
comme partout ailleurs sur terre,
ça n'avance pas assez vite,
quitte, au niveau de la Norvège,
à ouvrir de plus en plus
de champs de pétrole.
Musique douce
...
Elle rit.
C'est quoi, "Heidi's Ice" ?
Oh là là... Pff !
C'est ma plus grande
histoire d'amour, je crois,
ces glaciers.
C'est mes ex qui vont pas être
très contents...
Elle rit.
...d'entendre ça, mais...
Mais pour moi,
c'est... C'est...
Tout mon être, quoi,
est habité par ces glaciers
et c'est vraiment...
Pour moi, c'est toute ma vie, quoi.
Je vois pas comment je peux
me désolidariser, me détacher
de ces environnements-là
et pour moi,
c'est extrêmement important aussi
de faire en sorte
que ce ne soit pas que ma glace,
mais que ce soit
la glace de tout le monde.
C'est ce que j'essaie de faire tous
les jours, c'est de faire en sorte
que toutes les personnes
auxquelles je m'adresse,
elles aussi prennent
un petit bout de cette glace
et comprennent
à quel point cette glace,
elle est majestueuse,
à quel point c'est magique
quand tu regardes
des paysages pareils,
mais surtout à quel point
cette glace est importante
et qu'aujourd'hui, chaque mètre cube
de glace qui disparaît
est en train de tous nous impacter
et d'impacter
nos enfants, leurs enfants,
etc, etc,
sur des générations entières,
et pour moi,
d'arriver à partager ce message,
ça passe avant tout
par les émotions.
Au-delà des connaissances
scientifiques,
il faut que ça passe par le coeur
et c'est ce que j'espère
que les personnes qui regarderont,
en tout cas, ces documentaires-là
comprendront
à quel point
on a de la chance, quoi.
C'est un privilège pour nous,
encore aujourd'hui,
d'avoir des glaciers sur terre
et qu'il faut, tous ensemble,
tout faire pour les préserver
le plus longtemps possible.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Oh, c'est trop beau, là,
Pierre !